[Musique]
au revoir les enfants
j'espère aujourd'hui tiennent prends ta
chère petite échelle et descend vite
voir nico n'a pas trop neil était petit
neveu au lieu de siffler comme un gros
maire ce que je souhaitais pas trop ce
sport j'ai envie de m'amuser
on les jeunes effet la montée afin que
pierre à ses fins qui serait tout aussi
les oreilles seul si ben nous on se lève
toujours les oreilles
[Musique]
via leur mal à dompter mallette
m
[Musique]
salut les copains
ola olé hockey ou l'autre de nos
possibilités
quand j'ai vu ça suffit les autres ono
au lot au mercy patron vous êtes de
petits garnements
je suis moi qui voulais vous faire une
pause blog vous êtes petite jade allons
les enfants tous au dodo car demain rémi
toto et fanfan vont retourner chez leur
maman
alors en avant rémi toto pensons
nicolas ou pardon les enfants je me suis
trop attention
[Musique]
body petit comme dans le premier cas la
4 e mail
[Musique]
demain rémi toto et fanfan retourne chez
leur maman qui les attend avec
impatience ma chère soeur imee ville à
ce que va être contente de les revoir ce
petit pas trop un peu d'air pur de la
montagne le fera le plus grand bien à
laon en route fidèles copains au nos
patrons pas plus moi nous nous en route
non source d'ennui les enfants faites de
beaux rêves de vaud
[Musique]
en